On Journey to the Microcosmos, we love microbes.
We love to see them swim and wander and live
out their unique lives.
But we’ve also had to make peace with the
fact that the microcosmos is not a peaceful utopia.
This is a world where microbes are both residents
and food, which means that occasionally, we’ll
have to spend our time together watching organisms,
whose bodies are fractions upon fractions
upon fractions of a millimeter in size, turn
into vicious predators.
So today, in honor of both predator and prey,
we’re going to be revisiting some of our
favorite videos about eating in the microcosmos.
Grab a snack, and join our microbes as they
snack.
And we’ll start by revisiting some of the
clever
strategies that microbes use to gather their
prey.
Despite huge differences in morphology and
biological structures, all living organisms
do the same three basic things;
they get food, digest it, and excrete waste
materials.
Living organisms require energy to live.
Some produce their own food, usually through
photosynthesis, we call these autotrophs,
but many organisms cannot make their own food.
We call these heterotrophs and they...eat.
Among heterotrophic single-celled eukaryotes,
food is taken into the cell in various methods
but once it’s there, it's wrapped by
a membrane
and forms something called a food vacuole.
Then the cell flushes digestive enzymes inside
the food vacuole to start the digestion.
Nutrients are taken into the cytoplasm and
the waste material left in the vacuole then
basically fuses with the outer
membrane of the cell and what's left in the
vacuole is discharged into the environment
In some cases, like inside this beautiful
single-celled Nassula ornata which feeds on
filamentous cyanobacteria, content of the
food vacuole reacts with the digestive enzymes
and changes color.
But that process takes time.
Because each vacuole formed at a different
time, they are in different stages of digestion
which gives this cell it’s colorful polka
dots.
But how do these heterotrophic organisms get
their food?
Well, in spite of a remarkable
amount of diversity, a lot of microorganisms
use one of the same three strategies for getting
their food.
Some of this will be familiar to the macro
world
some of it will not.
One of the less familiar is filter feeding
which allows larger organisms to consume suspended
food particles or much smaller organisms.
There are filter-feeders in the macro-world,
baleen whales come to mind.
But while a whale must swim through giant
clouds of small organisms, in the microcosmos,
your food can come to you.
Some filter feeders use hair-like structures
called cilia to create a vortex that brings
other microorganisms or food particles to
the cell mouth.
These cilia are specialized for this task
and their beating creates a current that expediently
and beautifully directs every nearby thing
into the waiting mouth of the microorganism.
The cilia are often too small for us to see,
but you can see their effects.
Take a look at these Paramecia.
They're consuming tiny, tiny bacteria.
and you can see their cilia causing small
organisms to tumble across them.
You can also see all of their food vacuoles
on the inside,
and if you look very carefully, you can see
a new food vacuole forming,
getting filled up with those tiny, bacterial
cells.
Some of the best and most obvious filter feeders
are rotifers, micro-animals that use cilia
to create swirling vortices around their mouth
parts.
You can see how successful this feeding strategy
is by it’s belly full of algae cells.
Every time its mouth fills with more algea,
it contracts to swallow the food.
Now observe these single-celled organisms
called stentors,
they are much bigger than most other microorganisms.
You can actually see them with the naked eye.
and they also use filter feeding to push all
of their algal food into their cell mouths.
Our second feeding mechanism, maybe the most
familiar,
and the most exciting is called raptorial
feeding.
Raptorial feeders selectively capture prey
and hunt other organisms.
In this video you can see Dileptus hunting.
It paralyzes one organism with the touch of
its trunk-like proboscis, and then it pulls
that organism into itself
in a process called phagocytosis.
Many of these microorganisms are armed with
something called toxicysts.
These are little harpoon-like structures filled
with toxins and they are located on a particular
part of the cell which the microorganism uses
for hunting.
These tiny harpoons are then fired when they
come in contact with prey organisms
which then become immobilized.
This is Bursaria, it’s a single-celled organism
with a huge mouth, and things have not gone
well for the Paramecium that is now inside
it.
The Paramecium dies immediately because of
the toxicysts on the inside of the Bursaria,
so at least it was quick.
Now get ready for some truly gorgeous footage
of a micro-animal’s day going south.
First Paradileptus immobilizes the rotifer
with fired toxicysts and the animal is swallowed
by the single-celled organism
as it swims away.
This is a Frontonia which is a close relative
of Paramecia, but lacks the filter-feeding
habits of its relatives and feeds predaciously
on large diatoms and filamentous cyanobacteria
such as Oscillatoria here.
Though, in this case, it turns out this Frontonia
bit off a little more than he could chew.
Another raptorial feeding style is called
histophagy.
Histophagous organisms such as these single-celled
Coleps attack injured but live animals or
other single-celled organisms,
sucking off hunks of tissue
rather than consuming whole organisms.
When they attack an animal, they enter wounds
and ingest tissue often attacking in groups
because their chemical sensing abilities attract
many of them from a distance,
like microscopic vultures.
When a number of them gather in one place,
it’s hard to avoid another macro-world analog...piranhas,
devouring everything soft in no time at all.
There is a huge variety of raptorial feeding,
this is just the beginning, but we wanted
to show you one more before we move on.
This is Vampyrella, an amoeba with a suitable
name.
It specializes in feeding on filamentous
algae.
First, it bores a hole through the algal cell
wall and
then slurps out the gooey, nutritious cytoplasm.
Our final feeding mechanism, for today at
least,
is diffusion feeding,
in which the predator just sits in the same
place, relying
on the prey to accidentally make contact.
This is a Heliozoa, it’s a single celled
amoeboid and because of its resemblance to
the sun due to the rays coming out of its
cell, it’s sometimes called the “sun animalcule”.
The rays are called axopodia.
These are sometimes used in locomotion and,
in this case, for hunting prey.
Axopodia, are cytoplasmic extensions, meaning
they’re a part of the cell membrane, even
though they look like they’re sticking out
of it.
Each one has a central supporting
rod of microtubules that gives it this rigid
structure.
The axopodia are coated in organelles that
discharge toxins when touched, which impair
or even paralyze Heliozoa's prey.
After the organism is captured, those microtubules
are drawn back into the cell, thus retracting
the axopodia and allowing the cell to swallow
the unlucky organism, or prey is just engulfed
by extrusions from the cell called pseudopodia.
In this video, a rotifer has been captured
by a Heliozoa and it is slowly getting eaten by it.
Now this is something that happens fairly
freuently,
but we did capture something unusal here.
While it was stuck to Heliozoa's axopodia,
this rotifer actually lays its egg.
But neither egg nor the rotifer is going to
escape this.
Surprisingly heartbreaking.
This is a Suctorian, it is a ciliate just
like Paramecium and Stentor.
These organisms have hair-like cilia during
the early stage of their life, but as adults
they develop bundles of tentacles.
Just like in Heliozoa these tentacles are
supported by an internal cylinder of microtubules.
The tip of the tentacles have extrusomes;
these are special structures that attach to
and immobilize any other ciliates that touch
them.
The tentacles eventually penetrate the cell
membrane of the prey, and then the contents
of the prey is sucked out through the tentacle.
In the clip, a suctorian has caught 4 individual
Vorticella with its tentacles and is slowly
sucking their cytoplasm.
It looks a little like the vorticella have
the suctorian surrounded, but in fact, they
are powerless to escape it.
It’s a dangerous world out there.
The complex chemicals created by organisms
to sustain their life necessarily are useful
to other organisms, as building blocks and
as fuel.
And so predation evolved.
It’s beautiful, it’s constant, and it’s
brutal.
Now that we’ve seen how the hunters of the
microcosmos get their food, let’s experience
the more challenging part of the predator-prey
dynamic: getting eaten.
For the organisms in our next video, finding
themselves in the belly of the beast is just
the start of a more grueling process, one
that converts their bodies into nutrients.
Tardigrades are famous for their capacity
to survive.
If you look them up, you will be inundated
with long lists of the many things scientists
have thrown their way to see if the tardigrade
will survive.
We’ve made some lists like those ourselves.
Tardigrades on the moon, tardigrades in extreme
heat.
You’ve heard about them.
We’ve talked about them.
What else is there?
Well, here’s a surprising fact you might
not have known.
For certain species of tardigrades, like the
one in the middle of your screen right now,
you can tell the difference between a male
and a female by looking at their toes.
That’s right.
The toes.
These tardigrades are called Milnesium, and
the males of these species have a pair of
claws on their feet that are shaped a little
bit differently from the rest of the claws,
with only one hook on each claw instead of
the usual two.
But after taking a closer peek at this tardigrade’s
toes, we can confirm that she is a female tardigrade.
Now, that’s a fun fact for us as we watch
the clip.
But it does not actually do anything for the
poor rotifers that are surrounding this tardigrade,
who are currently stretching themselves in
and out of danger.
Around the tip of a tardigrade’s mouth are
small bumps that we think act like little sensors.
And when those bumps make contact with a rotifer,
out pops the tardigrade’s stylet—a needle
that pokes out from the tubular mouth opening.
That stylet pokes into the rotifer, and from
there the tardigrade uses a circular structure
called a pharynx in its head to create strong
suction.
And then, the stylet goes from functioning
as a needle to functioning as a portable,
built-in straw that lets the tardigrade suck
out the inside of its prey.
You can see some of the bodily fluid leaving
the rotifer as the tardigrade’s stylet pumps
away like a beating heart.
And when she is done, the rotifer remains,
like an empy coffee cup.
This method of eating works quite well for
the tardigrade, letting her eat quickly from
the prey that is directly in front of her.
But not all organisms come equipped with a
weapon that lets them turn rotifers into Capri Suns.
These organisms have to turn to other methods
to extract nutrients from their food.
This marine ciliate is called kentrophyllum,
and it came to James, our master of microscopes,
in a large container full of beach sand.
On a normal day, maybe we would talk more
about its funny almond shape that stretches
as it swims around.
But today is not a normal day because this
kentrophyllum is about to be overshadowed
by a rotifer.
Now, where is the rotifer, you might ask?
It is inside the kentrophyllum, of course.
We did not catch the moment of its capture,
when the toxic needles lining the kentrophyllum
darted out and paralyzed the rotifer.
By the time we arrived, the rotifer had already
been ingested…but it was not dead yet.
You can see it wiggling and wrestling at the
broad end of the kentrophyllum, causing the
ciliate’s body to wrinkle and fold in on
itself.
But it is trapped inside of a food vacuole
now, a compartment that exists to break this
rotifer down.
Sure, the rotifer can try and fight against
the walls of the vacuole holding it hostage.
But there’s not much it can do against the
digestive enzymes pouring in, or the increasing
acidity of its surroundings.
A food vacuole is a hostile place to be, and
for minutes, its destructive tools will go
to work.
In the end, the rotifer will be left in dissolved
pieces to be absorbed by the kentrophyllum’s
cytoplasm, sustaining the organism that was
the site of its last battle.
It’s a lonely death for the rotifer, with
only the kentrophyllum to witness it.
Though I suppose now there is also us, sharing
and immortalizing that rotifer’s last moments.
And if the rotifer had not died in the body
of another organism, it may have ended up
like this gastrotrich.
Now to be fair, they did find themselves in
a very similar situation: they are both dead.
But the rotifer was eaten alive,
digested from the outside
while trapped in another organism.
Meanwhile, this gastrotrich is going through
the exact opposite situation.
It is being eaten from the inside out, by
a scavenger called a peranema.
Now, as far as we know, the peranema didn’t
do anything to kill the gastrotrich.
It was likely already dead, though we don’t
know what killed it.
But the peranema is both a hunter and a scavenger.
Sometimes it can be found with other peranema
as they hunt down prey, in a pack of hungry microbes.
At other times, the peranema scavenges.
They are notorious for being able to squeeze
their way into whatever holes they find to
get into a dead organism.
And in this case, the gastrotrich’s exoskeleton
was the right combination of available, open,
and dead for the peranema, which found its
way in and decided to begin helping itself
to the buffet of dead tissue around it.
After all, the gastrotrich won’t be needing
that tissue anymore, so the peranema might
as well make good use of it.
The gastrotrich’s body has likely vanished
by now.
Perhaps the peranema will have finished it
off entirely, or some other scavenger will
have joined in on the fun.
Or perhaps, it will have simply faded, like
the rotifer inside the kentrophyllum, its
body eventually fading into the world that
encapsulates it.
But for this last moment, let’s remember
the gastrotrich in a more beautiful moment
under a fluorescent light, glowing in the
glorious purple autofluorescence of its remains.
If you think that microbes are the only organisms
that eat microbes, think again.
We humans have a particular fondness for one
specific fungus called Saccharomyces cerevisiae,
but you probably know better as “yeast.”
Often when we talk about the invisible role
that microbes have played in human history,
we’re talking about the destruction wrought
by diseases.
But as we’ll talk about in the next video,
the life of Saccharomyces cerevisiae has intertwined
with our own in ways that are both delicious
and mysterious.
Every time you eat a piece of bread or drink
a glass of beer, you are participating in
what might be (depending on how strict you
are about your definitions) one of the longest-running
microbiology experiments in human history.
While the earliest scientific studies of microbes
usually go back only a few centuries
when it comes to yeast, the microbe
at the core of some of our favorite foods
and drinks, well...those past few centuries
barely scratch the surface.
But before we get to that history, let’s
start with some of the basic biology.
Yeast are a fungus, though unlike many in
that kingdom, they don’t grow the branching
hyphae that characterize organisms like mushrooms.
Instead, yeast grow primarily through a process
of asexual reproduction called “budding.”.
While there are many yeast species found among
different fungal phyla, perhaps the most well-known
is Saccharomyces cerevisiae, which you might
see labelled as brewer’s yeast or baker’s yeast.
Along with a few other yeasts, these various
strains of S. cerevisiae are what we’ve
come to rely on for our beer, wine, and bread--and
all through the magic of fermentation.
Yeast, like many organisms, rely on different
metabolic pathways to break down sugar and
create energy.
These processes usually rely on oxygen.
But to deal with situations where oxygen may
be less readily available or some of their
key metabolic processes are shut down, yeast
turn to alcoholic fermentation.
Fermentation helps the yeast get the energy
it needs, but the particular chemical path
they follow also produces ethanol and carbon
dioxide.
The yeast doesn’t need these byproducts—in
fact, too much ethanol could be toxic for them.
But what is waste to a yeast is treasure to
us, and that shift in metabolic activity has
been making our bread rise and our brains
woozy for millennia.
Molecular studies of pottery jars found in
China found that they may have held some kind
of fermented beverage as far back as 7000
BCE.
And archaeological evidence has turned up
for leavened bread from 2000 BCE in Egypt
and 1000 BCE in North Western China.
It’s easy to see why our use of yeast has
persisted for millennia.
To quote one group of scientists, it helped
us make food and drinks with a
“enriched sensorial palate” and also
a “euphoriant effect.”
But the long-standing ubiquity of yeast also
emphasizes how mysterious their origins are.
We don’t actually know how yeast became
involved with our cooking.
We just know that it was ancient, likely starting
with wine, and would come to span continents,
potentially spreading through trade.
The results were food and drinks produced
through a series of observations about how
factors like temperature, time, and air might
affect the final product.
To quote Samuel Johnson’s 18th century dictionary,
barm--a type of yeast--is “the ferment put
into drink to make it work, and into bread
to lighten and swell it.”
At the time they didn’t know what was actually
in yeast or how it worked to shape those results.
We just knew it was a thing that provided…something…somehow….
Moreover, the earliest glimpses of yeast under
the microscope seemed to support the idea
that yeast was just some sort of chemical,
a fermenting agent, not a biological entity
of its own.
When Antoni van Leeuwenhoek observed yeast
in the 17th century, he thought they were
just bits of globular particles.
Against the new and incredible bits of life
he was seeing for the first time through the
microscope, yeast seemed useful but ultimately
unliving.
But over the next few centuries, as more scientists
worked to try and understand how fermentation
actually worked, they identified not just
the chemical reactions that shaped the process,
but that yeast was an actual living organism
essential to fermentation.
Eventually, Louis Pasteur would put all the
pieces together, publishing a paper titled
“The Memoir of the Fermentation of Alcohol”,
or something like that, but in French.
It was published in 1857 and it established
the interplay between chemistry and biology
that allowed yeast to turn to alcoholic fermentation
to survive.
He would also later uncover another form of
fermentation carried out by bacteria, which
is called lactic acid fermentation.
Pasteur’s work didn’t just change our
understanding of how bread was made, it would
go on to inform our understanding of germ
theory, and how the invisible world of microbes
connects to the grim realities of disease.
From this early history, yeast have gone on
to become perhaps one of the most studied
eukaryotic organisms in modern biological
research.
Saccharomyces cerevisiae in particular has
had an illustrious research career.
In 1996, its genome was fully sequenced, making
it the first eukaryotic organism to be genetically
mapped out.
Part of what makes yeast such great research
organisms is that they are easy to grow and
manipulate--both through environmental and
genetic means--which has allowed us to use
them to study everything from DNA replication
to prion diseases.
In the same way that cultures have refined
the ways we use yeast in our food and drinks,
scientists have refined the way we use yeast
in our lab experiments.
They’ve even developed genetic engineering
techniques that repurpose yeast to brew the
ingredients for everything from perfumes to
antimalarial drugs.
When you consider just how far we’ve come
with yeast, you might begin to wonder: did
we domesticate them?
After all, our early days of yeast use likely
coincided with our early days of plant and
animal domestication.
So in the same way that we’ve come to rely
on domesticated animals for food and labor,
maybe yeast are our microbial workhorses.
The answer to that question is one scientists
are still studying, in part because the history
of yeast is so large and mysterious, and in
part because domestication has a very specific
definition in these conversations.
One paper we found describes it as “human
selection and breeding of wild species to
obtain cultivated variants that thrive in
man-made environments, but behave sub-optimally
in nature,” now that’s quite a number
of nuanced requirements to check off.
But with this definition in mind, beer yeast
seems to show the most evidence for having
been domesticated, which is likely connected
to specific aspects of the brewing process
that have limited the exposure of the domesticated
yeast to wild yeast.
But all yeasts considered, the genetic analysis
of beer yeast strains show that this domestication
is actually relatively recent—as in, it
only happened a few centuries ago.
While it did happen before we even knew that
yeast was a living thing that we were domesticating,
it still came long after we started using
yeast to make beer, leaving much of the organism’s
history still a mystery.
It is often tempting to think that we have
a microbial world and a human world that intersect
only in chemical reactions and biological
connections.
But yeast reminds us that microbes are more
than just a scientific reality, they are a
cultural one--even when we didn’t know they
were around.
Yeast have created our foods, shaped our traditions,
and both bonded and divided us.
And how we use and change yeast will only
continue to shape our lives.
Their future, tied so much to our own, is
every bit as grand and mysterious as their
past has been.
There is but one inevitable way to end all
this, with poop.
Because yes, even microbes do it.
Not all that we eat can be retained in our
bodies, something must exit.
So come for the funny videos of microbes pooping,
stay for the extra lesson on how they do it
without a butthole.
Ah, food, one of life’s great pleasures.
Whether you’re an organism whose body can
create its own food, or you make do with the
consumption of other organisms, food sustains
and connects life both large and small.
But we’re not going to talk about food today.
We’re going to talk about what happens…after.
No great meal comes without consequences.
Even photosynthetic microbes produce oxygen
they don’t need, a byproduct that is quite
useful to many other organisms, including
us.
And for organisms that have to digest their
food to extract nutrients, well, there’s
all sorts of stuff left behind when the process
is done.
In the world of the microcosmos, there are
not only many varied tiny organisms.
There are also many varied ways to produce
even tinier poop.
And when we say “tinier,” we mean it.
If you’re worried about being grossed out
by this video, or you really want to make
sure you’re not missing anything, just know
that some of this pooping will require you
to pay very close attention.
Some of this will probably look similar to
macroscopic bowel movements,
and some will seem less so.
So let’s start with the more poop-like poop
that comes from some of the multicellular
members of the microcosmos, particularly the
ones with digestive systems complete with
specialized regions for digesting food and
releasing solid waste.
Our dragon-like friend the gastrotrich is
doing the old scrunch-and-poop, probably after
having finished a nice meal made up of bacteria
or protozoa.
The food came in through its pharynx and was
then sent through the intestine, a straight
tube full of digestive cells.
After, the remains continued their way to
the end of the tube, where lies the anus--a
microscopic gateway out of the gastrotrich
and into the world.
That’s all well and good for the more complex
organisms, but how does one poop when one
does not have a butthole?
Well, for some single-celled organisms, one
becomes the butthole.
Such is the case for amoebas.
Their formlessness allows them to easily shift
their shape around to take in food via phagocytosis.
The amoeba here happens to have found a nice
meal made of a ciliate, which is now contained
in a food vacuole filling with digestive enzymes.
Those enzymes will eventually break the ciliate
down, allowing the amoeba to absorb nutrients
into its cytoplasm.
But then what happens with the remains?
Well, as we see with this amoeba here, it
gets released.
Amoebas and other similar organisms use a
process called exocytosis to send waste back
to the membrane where it is removed from their
body.
You can see it again here in this Mastigamoeba,
slowly gliding along the microscope slide
while a round bit seems to come off up top.
It almost looks like it’s leaving behind
a little piece of itself, which I mean,
maybe it is.
Ciliates have a more refined approach to pooping,
which is to say they have the unicellular
equivalent of an anus called the cytoproct.
Ciliates gather food into an oral groove,
and then consume it in the digestive vacuoles
that travel through the cell.
Eventually, when the vacuole makes its way
to the cytoproct, the contents get out, and
there you have ciliate poop.
The way organisms poop—the way microbes
poop—are even more varied and wonderful
than we’ve been able to show you here.
But you might be wondering how you even get
from something relatively simple like this
ciliate releasing a small bit of waste to
something more complex, like this tardigrade
with its more compartmentalized approach to
defecation.
Well the answer, of course, is evolution,
but it’s an answer that leads to many more
unanswered questions.
Even within animals, the evolution of the
anus—or in some species, the cloaca—is
not well understood, as discussed in a 2015
review paper with the spectacular title, “Getting
to the bottom of anal evolution”.
While the anus itself is linked to the evolution
of a digestive system, not all metazoans have
a designated anus.
The hydra gut has only one opening, which
means that the organism’s mouth has to pull
digestive double duty and open back up to
release the waste.
And how that system fits in with the evolution
of digestion overall is unclear.
Much like the evolution of sex, anuses are
a trait that appears and disappears in evolutionary
lineages, reflecting the fact that they might
be useful for some animals and less so for others.
The duality of the hydra’s mouth seems to
be working out great for them after all.
But having a digestive system with a distinct
entrance and exit is pretty handy too.
For one, it’s just a little less disgusting.
But it also keeps food flowing in one direction.
And that means animals like the tardigrade
and us don’t have to wait to finish digesting
to eat more food.
That would be annoying.
We just get to keep eating, all thanks to
that evolutionary mystery that is the anus.
In the end though, anus or not, everybody
poops.
Food, after all, might be one of life’s
great pleasures, but all good things must
come to an end.
And perhaps, with the microcosmos, we can
find some pleasure in that as well.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The names on the screen right now, these are
some of our Patreon patrons, the people who
have decided to directly support this channel
over at patreon.com/journeytomicro, and we
thank them so much for their continued support.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram and TikTok.
And you can also find Journey to the Microcosmos
on TikTok now if you want some Micro Microcosmos
a couple times a week, and if you want to
see more from us here, there is always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby.